people who have diabetes have a higher
chance of developing many health
problems including heart disease
this video will show you how heart
disease can develop how it affects your
health and what you can do to help
reduce your risk of heart disease
if you have diabetes it means your blood
glucose or blood sugar is elevated
over time high blood sugar can damage
the blood vessels of your heart and
other organs leading to other health
problems
this means the longer you have diabetes
the greater your risk for heart disease
there are different types of heart
disease including coronary heart disease
cardiomyopathy arrhythmias and heart
failure
coronary heart disease is a buildup of a
cholesterol filled substance called
plaque inside the blood vessels of your
heart the buildup of plaque in coronary
heart disease can increase your risk of
having a heart attack
cardiomyopathy refers to diseases of
your heart muscle
cardiomyopathy may lead to abnormal
heartbeats called arrhythmias
cardiomyopathy may also lead to heart
failure
this means your weakened heart can't
pump enough blood to meet your body's
needs
having both diabetes and heart disease
can affect you in many ways
you will have a higher risk for other
serious health problems such as a heart
attack stroke and even death
it may be harder for you to go about
your daily activities
you may need help taking care of
yourself
you may also need to take more
medications
living with these conditions may cause
depression
the good news is that there are things
you can do to help lower your risk for
heart disease for example you may need
to make changes to your lifestyle
if you smoke get the help you need to
quit both smoking and diabetes can
narrow your blood vessels which can
increase your chance of developing heart
disease or stroke maintain or get to a
healthy weight
follow a healthy eating plan and get
regular physical activity check with
your health care provider about the
right amount of physical activity for
you make sure you work with your health
care provider to control your blood
sugar cholesterol and blood pressure
this includes taking all medications
prescribed by your health care provider
including insulin and pills to help
lower blood sugar blood pressure and
cholesterol
following the treatment plan you and
your health care provider discussed will
help you feel better and reduce your
risk of getting heart disease